today we are going to discuss about
multiomic research we will explore
several things today we'll discuss about
the research Fellowship training program
that commences in January we'll discuss
about the structure of the research
fellowship program and also we want to
discuss today about the different
possible omx analysis and also different
research specialization tracks that you
can work on once you have gained an
expertise on different omics analysis or
a speci specific one that is related to
your field after we have a sense of
different possible om analysis and
research specialization tracks we'll
take up a case study on a patient
derived xenograph model and explore how
an RN seek analysis could be done on
this specific case study we'll go
through the tbio info server pipelines
as well to see how we can uh perform an
Arn seek analysis and also we'll look
into the different types of open-source
tools resources softwares that you can
use for omix analysis not just limited
to the server but also the open resource
tools that you can use and yes the best
possible way to perform the analysis is
through Computing languages through R
and python so we'll also see how you can
learn the Computing languages R and
python to get a hold on performing seek
analysis once we have discussed the case
study and performed the Hands-On
analysis after that I'll share with you
some outcomes of the research fellowship
program that will definitely motivate
you to work on your own independent
research project and have your work
published so let's first of all discuss
what this entire research program is all
about so as students embark on their
professional Journey with friend freshly
completed degrees they often wonder how
the professional life will be different
from studies and many prepare for this
moment in advance by exploring the
possibilities to work in an area of
Interest through internships or research
fellowships during their studies itself
and the best way possible is that in
your academics you get an opportunity to
work on a research project most of you
who are from bachelor's and Masters
would definitely Ely have this project
section in their academics where you
have to work on a research project and
submit your desertation trust means not
just about a project but it also helps
you gain the skill set that is required
in the industry so this process starts
with the program with omix logic where
we have designed this entire structure
for students and also researchers B PhD
Scholars or researchers from industry
who are interested to get their hands on
a specific Comics analysis and build
their career around it so the entire
training program that we have built
together with the research component is
what I'm going to discuss today with all
of you now when I talk about the
research program we have divided it into
three different parts the first part is
training so when you start with the
research program we we don't expect you
to be well worsed with a specific type
of oring analysis if you are skilled
with a specific omic analysis then we'll
welcome you to our research part
directly but if not if you are a
bachelor or a master student we'll
motivate you to first of all identify
the area where you want to upscale
yourself be a genomic data analysis
transcriptomic data analysis metagenomic
single cell epigenomic so the Journey
Begins where you will first of all learn
about the basics of
bioinformatics identify an omx field
that you want to work with and then you
start your research work once you have
the training once you have that
expertise to work on a specific type of
omix analysis after that you start with
your research work now when it comes to
research work either you can work on a
research project independently or also
in a group and once you complete your
research project then you submit it as a
project report or a desertation to your
University College whatsoever your
requirement is or definitely proceed
ahead with a research publication